let's jump into this first story and
it's silly and it's stupid it's also
kind of creepy from the south china
morning post wwe superstar john cena is
very sorry to chinese fans for referring
to taiwan as a country in fast and
furious nine promotional interview isn't
this there's a ninth fast and the
furious move you guys it's the it's i've
long said the ffcu the best cinematic
universe anyway
john cena said on taiwanese tv that it
would be the first country to watch the
film american quickly the american
quickly backtracked on weibo saying he
made one mistake after doing a lot of
interviews it's it's it's kind of creepy
he said hi china i'm john cena i'm in
the middle of a fast and furious nine
promotions i'm doing a lot of interviews
i made a mistake in one of my interviews
everyone was asking me if i could use
chinese staff gave me a lot of
information so there was a lot of
interviews and information said cena who
started learning mandarin to help his
wrestling promotion integration in china
he has since gone viral many times for
his enthusiastic mandarin speaking
abilities
i respect him for trying absolutely i
made one mistake i have to say something
very very important now i love and
respect china and chinese people i'm
very very sorry about my mistake i
apologize i apologize i'm very sorry you
must understand that i really love
really respect china and the chinese
people my apologies see you all i heard
was please keep giving me money please
keep giving me money i don't want to
lose money
there are more than 5 000 comments on
cena's weibo apology quote please say in
chinese that taiwan is part of china
otherwise we won't accept it wrote one
weibo user the weibo user the message
has over 3 200 likes then you should say
taiwan is china's wrote another user
what you have said in the video is
nonsense you can't take benefits from
china but in the meantime do things to
harm china's interests others supported
cena with one person writing i like you
i think you truly love china don't talk
carelessly again about china's territory
and sovereignty
so of course it's it's a silly story in
a lot of ways i'm not sure how how much
it really matters but it's a grain of
sand and a bigger heap of many you know
companies sports
we had uh the nba you couldn't put free
hong kong on a jersey they wouldn't
allow it would say error can't you you'd
make a custom jersey and you're to put
free hong kong no can't do it we've seen
in many like uh esports people have said
free hong kong out
and so it's it's curious
you know we had cassandra fairbanks on
and she made really good points about
not wanting to go to war with china
under any circumstances even the things
we're seeing that are bad and there's
some deep philosophical philosophical
questions here the big thing i take
issue with with things like john cena
being deferential to china is that
there's clearly american interests
is he more interested in making money
by expanding his business into china
which means supporting chinese interests
against american interests there's i
don't think there's a way to to
play both sides on this one right in
america we as a country we respect
taiwan
as a country we do so you you know
people our rights are allowed to have
their own opinions john cena wants to be
i guess he wants to be in line with
china because he's got money to be made
there and so what ends up happening is
china doesn't tolerate the free speech
in the same way the u.s does john cena
can say this what's the worst gonna
happen we're gonna insult him maybe if
he says something truly egregious we'll
boycott him in china he he has to come
out and apologize in the us he wouldn't
do it so that means so long as they're
more
authoritarian in their speech or i
should say
more
collectivist than they're going to keep
winning a lot of these corporate battles
which means a lot more resources will
flow towards china away from the u.s and
that will incentivize the political
class to continue extracting resources
through sending our manufacturing and
things like that but in terms of the
bigger the broader point which is
thucydides trap you're probably familiar
with this yeah
scott
which is
are we heading towards war with china
because of their economic expansion
i'm curious just is you know your
thoughts i guess is it a good thing or a
bad thing my personal opinion i think
it's really bad because
i think a lot of what we're seeing with
these corporations going to china is bad
because i'm concerned about
individualism liberty and what happens
to the world if china becomes a
superpower that
supplants the us and starts doing what
the us is doing but with chinese
communist authoritarianism instead of
classical liberalism i understand from a
historical perspective not from the
current american perspective but the
very least we have a constitution right
sure so i'm curious what do you think
well listen i mean i think you're on to
something that it's a real worry when
american
you know media characters and companies
are so heavily invested in china are so
heavily dependent on
uh on chinese money that then
you know it undermines american values
like free speech and things like you're
talking about there
we saw this with and you know we're at
the humorous stage of this right it
could get a lot worse you know john cena
and some basketball players and stuff
right the one that i thought was really
funny was when they remade red dawn
yeah i'm an 80s kid so i love the
original red dawn in fact i just watched
it recently and it's just hilarious and
wonderful um but i watched the remake of
it and it's just an absolute catastrophe
and the movie
it was i guess it came out like pretty
near after the 08 crash and so the idea
was that the american government clearly
after george w bush was so irresponsible
right that and had had run america in
the ground so badly that then the
chinese were going to take the advantage
and conquer north america which is about
as easily as the russians doing it back
in the 80s by the way but it was north
korea wasn't it yeah well they switched
it right so this is what happened when
they filmed the movie they had
um i remember there's a lady named karen
decoster that wrote for lou rockwell.com
that was talking about how they were
filming the movie in chicago and they
had big red chinese flags hanging down
and all these things she's like oh
they're remaking red dawn and it's china
this time but then by the time the movie
came out it wasn't china anymore now
it's north korea
and so if you watch it then like the
beginning of the movie is like a 10
minute or like a little five minute news
montage to try to explain the story of
how north korea ended up conquering all
of asia and then came across the pacific
ocean for us next it's just the most
ridiculous thing and the movie was just
terrible anyway it had no redeeming
quality anyway but it was just the fact
that they had to change it from
something that was
mildly plausible right like china is
they gotta sell the movie
yeah they have to sell the movie in
china so they had to change it and so i
think that could be a problem but i
think look overall
the more investment that we have in
china and the more investment that they
have here the better off we all are and
the safer we are from violent conflict
that's the famous quote from frederick
bastiat where goods did not cross
borders soldiers will and so we're
better off if you remember when china
shot down the spy plane in 2001 and
colin powell made peace real quick said
sorry and then i forgot if they got the
plane back or not but but they resolved
it really quickly and that was because
of wall street and and the amount of
investments that they have in china
dictated that we keep things cool but
now there's a there's another major
competing interest in corporate america
besides you know walmart and all those
guys and that is the ship builders and
the long-range bomb man bomber
manufacturers and they have a major
interest in pursuing cold war with china
and ratcheting these things up right so
we have in a way is a war between big
business factions in america those who
want to import and sell cheap crap or
whatever it is versus those who want to
sell weapons to the captive market that
is the pentagon and those are huge big
ticket items when you're talking about
the next generation long-range bomber
billion dollars no i i think
i think it is true right trade lines
make it harder for there to be war the
problem is
everybody thought that with with opening
up trade to china they would start to
adopt more of of our values and it seems
like that's not happening they're
actually the chinese communist party is
still very much ideological
ideologically driven and in control of
most of these companies and it seems
like it's actually just resulting in the
extraction of american manufacturing
wealthy elites have found a path towards
extracting
the labor from the u.s making money by
shipping things overseas and there's
there there is very much that idea i
think you know
we saw this with a lot of the
establishment democrats 10 years ago the
trans-pacific partnership this idea like
oh okay let's give them a bunch of stuff
with this trade deal it'll make it
harder for there to be war but the tpp
was was was nightmarish trump was like i
got to shut this down there was you know
ian often uh often brings it up that the
corporations and foreign countries could
then sue americans yeah the investor
state dispute settlement clause in the
tpp said that if we wanted to not buy
malaysian oil for some reason they could
sue us for discrimination and then the
taxpayer would have to fund this the
lawsuit what ends up happening is
while it may be true or that in many
circumstances you'll get some crossover
where people might actually come
together that means we have to start
adopting
chinese ideological i should say the
communist party's ideological values
well it doesn't mean that right i mean
for example these basketball stars or
whoever could go a lot more broke
crossing the american people and selling
out our values of free speech than
pleasing the chinese right i mean is
john cena going to sacrifice his
american audience for a chinese one or
he wants to have it both ways but this
is this is the issue that i was
mentioning that
the ramifications from the
american audience who aren't paying
attention to politics is that they're
going to shrug and say i don't care
whereas
the chinese audience is very much
heavily invested and very very you know
pro-china so john cena could come out
and say
you know look it's it's it's where's the
most damaged if he says taiwan is a
country then he loses tons of money in
china if he says taiwan is not a country
then nothing's going to happen to the
united states so he defers to china you
that that's a grain of sand you do that
over and over again eventually you have
this heap where you look at the
companies that want to be in in china
google for instance in order for a
company to operate in china they have to
have a chinese communist party member in
that company in that office in the
country so now google starts you know
you start seeing protests in the u.s
when google was developing a chinese
censored search engine right people
protested google claims shut it down i
guess i'm not sure we have to have the
experts back on but there's report
rumors that google just decided to just
give in and start doing what they wanted
um the american people too many of them
don't care and don't pay attention and
so because of that these companies are
like what's our risk you can piss off
americans but americans don't pay
attention so they probably won't do
anything anyway but these other
countries that are much more invested in
their country will get mad so let's just
make sure we're keeping them happy and
then over a long enough period of time
it seems like we're becoming too
different to china because our business
interests are yeah but then again look
at all the backlash against the nba
stars who
uh you know said everybody be quiet
about hong kong or whatever a couple
years ago and i don't know exactly the
backlash against cena but there's
there's a substantial one about this
right he's be clowning himself
selling out selling out you know what he
obviously thought
as you just said all i hear is money
money money
right which by the way
you know the situation with taiwan is
very complicated because after the civil
war the nationalists escaped to taiwan
and then the americans sailed the
the seventh fleet in there i guess right
and prevented mao's forces from
following them and conquering them and
then from 1949 through like 74
america only recognized taiwan as the
official legitimate government of china
even though
they really only ruled this tiny island
and all of mainland mainland china was
had been under the rule of the maoists
for by that time like 30 something years
and so nixon and kissinger in a move
that was really
made to one screw the soviet union and
two
kind of ameliorate from the fact that he
was pulling us out of vietnam by saying
well don't worry about the domino effect
because we made friends with the mouse
so now that we're friends with china it
doesn't matter so much that we're losing
in vietnam and so
they recognize china as you know the the
communist government in beijing as the
official government of china which was
only reasonable but then they adopted
this policy of strategic ambiguity when
it comes to the fate of taiwan and so
america has no treaty with taiwan and
we're not sworn to protect them but
since nixon and various presidents say
this in different ways trump almost
accidentally changed the doctrine in the
way that he stated it but then his state
department walked it back but
essentially the position is that there
is one china
and the government in beijing is the
official government of all of china
including taiwan but that america will
always oppose the reunification by force
but then in what way will we oppose it
will we sell f-16s to taiwan
if so how many and then if that doesn't
work then what and this is the real
crisis now is let's say that the chinese
decide that we're taking back taiwan
next year
what's america going to do about it joe
biden
well what's any american president
what's your favorite american president
going to do about it he's going to get
into a nuclear war he's going to lose
tokyo and honolulu and los angeles in
exchange for taipei
and what do we get out of that nothing
and what do we really care if the
chinese conquer taiwan what difference
does that make to you or me at all other
than we're against war we don't want to
see anybody violently killed well but in
terms of the american people's national
interest
there's not one town much less major
city we should be willing to trade for
taipei and by the way if we got into a
nuclear war with china over taiwan
they'd get taiwan at the end of the day
anyway we'd end up losing la in san
francisco and getting nothing out of it
in exchange already like in my mind i
can see like the the
the path of like the conflict and the
arguments over for and against that i
hear so often from
i wouldn't necessarily say the pro-war
people but the like
and i don't think well there's probably
people say they're pro-war for sure but
most people try to pass it off like it's
war essentialism like i wish we didn't
have to have it right we do well see
this is what you're talking about with
the i always forget how to pronounce it
the great trap there the thucydides trap
thucydides trap through acidities
through city like i never said he was a
guy so but here's the guy
the thing of it is that
if america would just renounce our world
empire which we're not supposed to have
in the first place that's right then it
wouldn't matter that china is the rising
power the reason this is a trap is
because america has declared that the
entire pacific ocean is an american lake
and we won't settle for only 99 percent
all of it belongs to us or will go to
war over the idea but that's not
legitimate so if china becomes again the
dominant power in east
asia as it's always been for thousands
of years then
we have to go to war against that or we
have to recognize that this is the
middle part of north america and that
sounds to me like japan and korea and
vietnam's problem not mine
yeah i mean if you look back at the the
i would assume a lot of the intent of
the founding fathers was not to do any
of this but at a certain they warned us
explicitly against foreign engagement
like this in entangling alliances
whether you know with european powers or
anyone else you could imagine and and it
just changed foreign intervention all
all together world war one i think it
changed everything that's right all of a
sudden yeah all of a sudden now it was
uh
every war was our responsibility we
became the world police
so so but let's get a little
philosophical i suppose
if
so we've had different experts you know
on talking about china sure if if biden
can't defend taiwan
then we can already see china's
expansion the claims of the south china
sea the attacking of the vietnamese
fishing vessels they'll just expand and
exert influence and take over and so the
fear is
what happens if the u.s does nothing do
we eventually have a china that does
what the u.s does and do you want i
don't think so i don't think so but look
at the what i mean by the road
initiative they would be insane to look
at what america's done for the last 20
30 years and say let's replicate that
we'll build 800 bases all around the
world and then we'll kill two million
iraqis and syrians and yemenis and then
we'll blow our own brains out and our
civilization will collapse
why would they do that could they
possibly be as dumb as the bushes in the
clintons they're building their bases on
nuclear submarines so they're mobile and
underwater they are expanding the tolls
but but i will say this i do think there
is a certain efficiency in the chinese
communist party's authoritarianism i'm
not saying it's a good thing i'm saying
that you rule with an iron fist they
dictate and they have a plan for what
they're going to do whereas in the u.s
we have regime change every four years
almost like one guy wants to go blow up
this country george george w is mad
about you know saddam and his dad's
fight so he wants to bring it back then
obama's like i guess there's money we
made so joe biden gets his brother some
contract deals in iraq when you look at
what's happening in the u.s it's the
extraction of value for personal gain
yeah and it leads us i look at what what
the authoritarian you know the chinese
communist party what they do is it's
rigid it's constructed it's control
there's a plan there they they're very
rigid and i look at the us and it's
chaotic exploitation by the elites they
don't care about you they don't care
about us but you really think the
chinese plan is world empire rather than
just short
their own area i don't know it looks
like a desperately poor country with
millions of of hungry people but look at
what they've been doing in africa south
america that what was it the belt and
road initiative
that's all men with briefcases right
that's not militarism
so it's i mean they have a tiny little
military base in djibouti right
otherwise they traipse across africa we
got special operations forces in right
right more than half the countries in
africa they've got guys with briefcases
doing capital investments
which is interesting because
it's a chinese communist party using
capitalism using capitalist enterprise
to gain control they're buying up tons
of our land so my fear is
i i would not want to live the way
people in hong kong are currently you
know with all the changes and the people
being arrested and in mainland china
i like being able to tell you know i
don't care who the president is to you
know to f off or whatever but uh they've
all
there's been direct economic competition
between china and the us i don't
necessarily think warfare needs to
always be hot with guns and so what
happens when
yes through economic exploitation
we end up deferential to the chinese
communist party i'm not i'm not in any
way advocating for with the us's stupid
plans with sending guys with guns all
over the place because you can clearly
see that china using investment is doing
way better in many ways we are wasting
time and money because we have
corporations we have big military
industrial you know companies that just
want to expand and make more even when
the when congress says or even when the
army is like we don't need any more
tanks congress is like rubber stamp
anyway we just make them it's good for
the economy right china is more
strategic so they got a longer plan than
us and i do think
i'm i'm not going to be happy uh i think
most people wouldn't be happy if they
had to live the way people in mainland
china do yeah
well i mean
it's kind of a leap though from john
cena
to
all of us having to apologize to the
children all day for for this that or
the other thing of course
their military doctrine our government's
acronym for it or you know the way they
call it i don't know exactly the chinese
term for it is
anti-access
area denial
in other words it's purely defensive
their entire military strategy is about
keeping the united states out but
so yeah but it's not a blue water navy i
mean you talk about uh nuclear
submarines we have 22. aircraft carriers
11 on station around the planet at all
times the u.s navy rules all the oceans
in the seven seas the the question here
is
do we rule
all of the south china sea or does
china have influence in the south china
sea and think how absurd this would be
if we were talking about china's
influence in the gulf of mexico right
right and
the atlantic ocean is now a chinese lake
i i i be absolutely absurd in the same
way that our claim to the pacific ocean
and all of those territories is absurd
so yes we we are in a trap if we are
pledged to defend the koreas and japan
and laos and cambodia and vietnam and
australia and every other and what uh
myanmar and every other country in asia
from china then yes we are definitely in
a greek guy trap and we're going to have
we got here
thucydides but but the reality is that
that's not in the interest of the
american people whatsoever so right if
the chinese
like you're talking about the difference
between
the people that run the american
government have all these very narrow
interests and the chinese government
seems to have kind of broader plans
i don't think that makes them
necessarily any more of a threat you
know the defensive pact of world war one
is basically what started it someone had
a pact with i don't know was that the
austrian hungary hungarian empire or
something yeah the germans and the
ottomans and then
so if someone got invaded then there was
a defensive response so like if if
taiwan was invaded in the american
defensive response would kick off a
bunch of nations joining and defending
each other and then a world war but when
you look at world war ii hitler invaded
poland and if we had not done anything
they set up basically they used the
conquered area of poland to build more
military they were using their industry
so it was they were planning to invade
russia
so at what point if you see a foreign
invasion do you do you intervene
well that's the deeply that's the deep
philosophical debate when they attack
you
but what if they attack everyone around
you and start building more weapons with
that industry well look france is not
around me and this was the lie of the
1930s and early 40s was that look france
is our eastern frontier
well no it's not it's like 5 000 yeah
france is not part of america at all and
it's not our frontier at all these are
all just figures of speech right and in
fact you know if the
british hadn't given a war guarantee to
poland
then hitler would have never turned west
against france and denmark and belgium
and england and the western democracies
in the first place as you say he was
they split poland he split poland with
the soviet union
and on
and made a peace with them because he
knew that he was going to have to fight
them sooner or later but the british and
the french were insisting on fighting
him
so he decided to turn against to make a
peace with stalin
and fight and destroy all the western
democracies first
and then move into the soviet union so
if the british had just stayed out of it
once he went into poland then war
between nazi germany and the soviet
union was inevitable and he would have
never
felt like he had to attack the western
democracies at all the whole thing would
have been in the east which would have
been a catastrophe for the people in the
lands between germany and the soviet
union but not for the western
democracies it was it was this all was
self-inflicted in fact if you read pat
buchanan's book churchill hitler and the
unnecessary war they talk about when
neville chamberlain everybody always
makes fun of neville chamberlain for
making uh peace over czechoslovakia
right yeah but he's the one who he gave
the war guarantee to poland and as soon
as he did lord gray the foreign minister
said oh my god what are you doing they
should lock this man up in a mental
hospital are you crazy why would you
give a war guarantee to poland we have
no ability to defend poland
all you're doing is guaranteeing that
we're going to get into a war with
germany that we're not prepared to fight
yet i mean what does any of this have to
do with fdr and the american people back
home other than his new deal failed for
three administrations in a row and so
now he had to get us into a war so why
did uh why did hitler attack uh the uk
because they declared war on him first
is that what happened that's what
happened yeah when they listen when that
war was over
when that war was over winston churchill
said you know
i guess we stuck the wrong pig
well didn't joe yeah really huh germany
had a military force in their west
preparing to invade france regardless i
think because they were ready to go when
france declared war they went like two
weeks later they went in to paris
with tanks well i i don't want to
do it
yeah yeah yeah
because i want to i want to have a
belligerent that is going to invade at
what point do you say that's declare
counter war the philosophical question
that i wanted to get to before we
started going off on you know history
stuff is
i guess the philosophical argument for
those that are war essentialists is that
well
if we don't do it they will and i'd
rather be on top of the mountain than
you know the bottom of it and that's
like a very nightmarish prospect but
i i think
i don't know do you cross your fingers
and hope no one's going to do it yeah i
think they would though no i don't think
they would you think only america is the
country that wants to have these bases
well look the american people are the
only ones who can afford it and we can't
even afford it yeah yeah the chinese
candidate because of the petro dollar
it's all looking and the reality is we
had in the cold war with the soviet
union this bipolar world where this
really america ruled two-thirds of the
planet and the communists ruled
one-third of it right and then when all
that fell apart this is what charles
krauthammer the neocon called our
unipolar moment this is when we get to
spend the next about 20 years making the
world exactly how we want it
before not that america will get weaker
but before the rest of the world starts
getting rich and their power starts
becoming more equal to ours and then so
this has been seen all along as an
eventuality that what we'll have is a
multi-polar world thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you